[Applause]
[Music]
Ukraine is the Paris Hilton of countries
anytime it's in the news it's not for
anything good in the last few decades
Ukraine has been the scene of the worst
nuclear catastrophe in history and
military conflicts with Russia and the
biggest corruption scandals that you
could ever imagine
[Music]
but there's another thing Ukrainian
politicians have in common with Paris
Hilton they both have a lot of money
after the fall of the Soviet Union
Ukraine's economy stopped being managed
by the state and started being managed
by the states friends these are these
so-called oligarchs and you can find
them in all of the countries political
parties whether they're pro Russia or
anti Russia so for example the current
president Petro poroshenko is known as
the king of chocolate because he owns
the biggest chocolate company in the
country
[Music]
and the former president Yulia
Tymoshenko is known as the gas princess
because she made a lot of money in the
gas industry in other words more things
change the more they stay the same
nonetheless things they are really
starting to change in Ukraine but do
make no mistake these changes they are
not for the better
in fact rather the opposite is true you
see in a previous video we told you how
Russia is Europe's main gas provider for
example Germany by 60% of their natural
gas from Russian companies like Gazprom
and Rosneft and how does this gas arrive
well most of it comes from gas pipelines
that cross Ukrainian soil well so what
does all of this mean well it means that
despite Ukraine having little gas
resources they are still a hot spot in
this business and this this is where
Vladimir Putin enters the picture
do this de Putin needs Ukraine to supply
Europe with gas but as you know the
relationship between Putin and Kiev
currently has a status of it's
complicated to rather say the least
so after decades of lovin Slavic
fraternity the government of ukrainian
president poroshenko wants to stay away
from putin as much as possible as you
can imagine this political divorce it's
not exactly making russia happy anytime
there gas goes through ukrainian
territory they have to pay a
millionaire's share of alimony to their
ex-wife but this is not the end of our
story as long as ukraine is the center
of the key gas routes Kiev will have a
better position to negotiate with Moscow
and even with Brussels in other words
Ukraine matters as long as we need them
for gas all right so what is Putin's
strategy well check this out
[Music]
Russians insist on new pipeline to
bypass Ukraine and Europeans are fine
with it
yes dear viewers Russia wants to take
Ukraine out of that gas root equation
this way Ukraine would lose their
strategic value which would also mean
that neither America nor the European
Union would really care about them in
the case of a new Russian invasion so
the question is well can this strategy
actually work will the European Union
let Russia
bypass Ukraine well today we are going
to answer all of these questions but as
we always do let's take a look back at
the history
if you're not mine then you won't be
anyone elses in the Year 2070 percents
of the Russian gas arriving from Europe
came from Ukraine more specifically it
came from the so called
Brotherhood gas pipeline this pipeline
was built in the times of the Soviet
Union and it became more important as
the demands for Russian gas grew the
other 30% came from the Yamal pipe in
belarus that's a story for another day
when the Soviet Union fell apart Ukraine
became an independent nation and this
this was the moment when key politicians
in Kiev started to see the business
clearly
they basically thought while Russia has
the gas reserves but they need to
Celsius to get to the Germans so this
repairs affair that seems fair nowadays
this fair is still more than 2 billion
dollars a year but it used to be even
higher thanks to these so-called transit
rights this state-owned Ukrainian gas
company called NAFTA gas became an
absolute bear moth and all of this with
basically having no gas resources in
their own country as you can imagine
this isn't just about economics both in
Russia and Ukraine everything's a
political weapon so anytime Kiev had a
Russian friendly government Gazprom sold
them cheap gas but when Kiev didn't have
Russian friendly politicians in office
while the prices went sky-high
we actually already discussed this in
another video the first one in this
series on Russian gas the gas
negotiations between Russia and Ukraine
they led to a supply cut in 2000 and
2009 in 2009 this is actually caused the
rest of Europe to go without gas as well
and this this was when Russia started a
new strategy
Putin picked up the phone to his friend
he used to be the German Chancellor and
is now the president over Rosneft his
name is Gerhard schröder and Gerhard
schröder he phones the current German
Chancellor and that's of course Angela
Merkel this is how they sold them on the
first project to bypass Ukraine and
that's the Nord Stream one pipeline this
pipeline goes straight through the
Baltic Sea from Russia direct to Germany
one year later in 2010 Yanukovych won
the Ukrainian policy you knew the vege
is a pro-russian politician so the good
times and the cheap gas but it came back
[Music]
but in 2014 we had the ERM iDEN drew
those protests in Kiev well they took
Yanukovych out of office and brought a
brand new anti Russian government to
Ukraine and this is where Putin
essentially said if I can't have you
nobody can since 2015
Gazprom the main Russian gas company
started the ultimate plan to bypass
Ukraine the one hand they started Nord
Stream to through the Balta
and on the other hand on the southern
side Gazprom is building the Turks
stream that sends gas through the Black
Sea to Turkey according to the Gazprom
president by the year 2020 the good old
Brotherhood pipeline will carry less
than 10% of what it used to carry but
hold on a second because so far it just
seems like Russia is just plain bad and
Ukraine is just a poor victim here right
well in fact things are way more
complicated than that so should we dive
a little deeper maybe
[Music]
the Ukrainian juggernaut NAFTA gas is
far more than a gas company in fact it's
kind of a job agency they have more than
a hundred and seventy-five fouls and
workers put that in some perspective by
the way the national gas company of
Poland's which is also owned by the
state only employs 25,000 people in
other words in Ukraine yet nobody if you
don't have a relative who works for
NAFTA gas as you can imagine NAFTA gas
is a black hole on Ukraine's finances
it's sort of like if Paris Hilton was
doing her own accounting with so many
people working for a state-owned
enterprise money disappears and nobody
knows why according to the Institute for
European research and policy consulting
a crane Ian think-tank NAFTA gas loses
more than three billion dollars a year
from corruption this company is always
reporting financial losses and we aren't
talking about a little bit of money here
just in 2014 after gas losses accounted
for 6% of the entire Ukrainian GDP but
right then in 2014 we had the euro
Maiden and this went very fast changes
changes like this one Ukrainian police
detains Naftogaz chairman of board yevon
buck Whelan the new CEO of the company
is this man you see on the screen now
andre kabul EF a 40 year old consultant
his job could be summarized in two goals
ending corruption and ending russian
dependency and i mean i wonder well is
he actually serious about this well so
far things has actually looked kind of
good both the European Union and the IMF
of pushed Ukraine to do their homework
and it seems like they're actually
trying PSE announces new improvements of
the storage transparency initiative
Naftogaz of Ukraine joins gas storage
inventory a GSI plus since then NAFTA
gas has started to make a profit after
decades of losses they now account for
13% of the state's income and now you
might be wondering well what did Kolya
do was the magic formula first of all as
is always the case with state monopolies
the prices were controlled by the
government
this means really cheap gas and
Ukrainian consumers who were
used to paying these artificially low
prices now and after gas has raised
prices to a level equal to that of other
European countries
second of all Kabul EF has confronted
Putin with a lot so let's call it
lateral thinking
you see Gazprom wanted to raise gas
prices for Ukraine but not for the rest
of the European countries so what did
you crane do instead of fighting with
Moscow they started to buy gas from
other European countries like Slovakia
but hold on a minute because you might
be thinking now well does so lucky
actually have gas resources I've never
heard of that and no they don't
but here's what happened the contracts
with Gazprom say that once the gas
arrives in an EU country Russia loses
control over this means that the buyer
can do whatever they want with the gas
once it shows up
so Slovakia gets their Russian gas
through the Brotherhood pipe and then it
sends it back through the same pipe to
Ukraine
so Slovakia buys Russian gas and then
Ukraine buys it from salokya thanks to
this Naftogaz has cut their importing
cost by a quarter but this is just the
beginning
couple you have keeps looking for
alternatives for example he's looking to
Azerbaijan as we said in other videos
Azerbaijan has lots of gas they are
indeed building a pipeline the trans
Anatolian which goes to Italy Kiev wants
to connect to this pipe through Bulgaria
but this is going to be something that
we're going to dig into in a future
video because believe me Azerbaijan is
another interesting topic that deserves
a video all of its own if you don't want
to miss that well don't forget to
subscribe so let's go back to our story
it seems that Ukraine is doing a great
job cleaning up corruption right well
hold on a minute because as we always
say on official politic not everything
is sunshine and rainbows if Ukraine
wants to fully adapt to European
standards they should liberalize their
gas market this would mean that NAFTA
gas would no longer be a monopoly and
they would have to split up the company
into several smaller companies one would
be focused on gas production and other
would manage domestic consumption and so
on and so forth as you can imagine this
this is where some problems and gonna
come into the picture
[Music]
you and Ukraine in tug-of-war over
Naftogaz unbundling as you can imagine
as much as probably ever wants to clean
up the company too many oligarchs have
been too good to the company for too
long now the company might be owned by
the state but this is not a reason not
to have millionaire salaries and
millionaire bribes right and the reality
is this is something that is really hard
to stop overnight but this isn't the
worst part you see in March of 2019
Ukraine they're gonna have elections
again and the result it's gonna be
decisive for NAFTA gases future and as
you might imagine the viewer Russia do
have a well-defined agenda for this so
let's have a look at it
[Music]
economics versus geopolitics Germany has
made it all clear they will build the
Nord Stream 2 pipeline
[Music]
both Brussels and Washington are against
it in fact Donald Trump has been the
biggest critic he essentially said that
even Paris Hilton would do a better job
than Germany when it comes to having
good energy policies and now he might be
wondering well how is it possible Angela
Merkel as let herself be seduced by
Vladimir Putin yes I mean you know that
the former German Chancellor Gerhard
Schroeder is Putin's nanny in Europe but
this is a lot more to it than that the
basic situation is Germany I have a big
dilemma on one hand their industry needs
gas and a lot of it the safer and
cheaper and cleaner it is the better and
putting politics aside nordstrom to is
the best option for their economy it's
cheap and it avoids gas Wars with
Ukraine the problem is that this gas
pipeline would make Germany even more
dependent on Russia meanwhile Putin is
pretty happy you can bypass the Ukraine
and you can also destroy their economy
in this regard Russia's intentions are
pretty darn obvious about this so you
want an example of that well take a look
at this map this is the vaccine this
little sea to the north is the Azoff see
both seas are connected by the Kerch
Strait and ukraine they've got two
important harbours in the A's of C's or
wanted Russia do well they built a
bridge right at the Kerch Strait a
bridge that makes most of the ships
unable to arrive or leave the Azov sea
this is why you hear so much on the news
about military escalation in this region
so now you might be wondering well why
is Russia trying to bankrupt Ukraine is
it all about jealousy and no absolutely
not the thing is the worst the anti
Russian Ukrainian government does the
better things are for the pro-russian
candidates in the elections
and are there any pro-russian candidates
running in the 2019 Ukrainian elections
well the answer is well yeah anything's
pretty much possible here's an example
of how crazy this country can be in
Ukraine they have this TV show called
servant of the people the star is a
teacher who fights corruption and here's
the thing there's an actual political
party that is based on this television
series the actor who plays the role of
the teacher is actually began edit his
name is Vladimir zalenski and well does
he have any chance of winning well have
a look at this Jenko leading
presidential candidate Paul followed by
poroshenko zalenski and hit Cinco you
heard that right he is in third place
followed by the king of chocolate and
the gas princess so essentially it's
pretty much impossible to predict what's
actually gonna happen there is just one
thing that is clear in this story and
that's that azerbaijan is already having
a really good time we're gonna talk
about that in the next video but in the
meantime the question for you is well
what would you do if you would germany
would you take that cheap Russian gas in
exchange for leaving Ukraine alone or
would you sacrifice competitiveness for
political interest well please leave
your answer in the comments section
below
also do visit reconsider mediacom the
podcast that provided the vocals in this
episode but we're not mine also if you
like this video give us a thumbs up and
as always I'll see you next time and if
you want to learn more about politics
and here even more of my lovely voice
you can join us at reconsider media we
have a podcast at reconsider mediacom
slash podcast see you there